I had two proofs of battery the
second when he showed me
something he showed what it could
give later when I have
developed and suddenly it made me
tremble doing it was my main
in first and last year  took me
under his wing throughout
the year the task but I have lots of
teachers who inspired me I have my
theater teacher in high school also allowed me
to learn to speak in front of people
without having the stress etc
so that that my wife helped me a lot
in my life athena fidus grannies
made him sweat he is a history teacher who
tells the story like stories
and that was cool because they
showed all the coherence of why
it happened like that how
things came together late
the fascinating story of toronto
always presented like st jean
he was passionate about his subject he
had the English words he had the
English accent and to  every time people
ask me where I got my accent  English
it's also thanks to him it's thanks to
him that I'm calmer
[Music]